listen to what I am saying if you do
what I'm about to tell you you can
immediately make more money in your
business no matter what you sell close
more deals it doesn't matter invent or
create a level of service that is 10
times higher than your most expensive
thing here's what's going to happen
number one in the rare scenario you're
actually talking to a whale a luxury
buyer and they will automatically always
look at the menu find the most expensive
thing and say that's what I want and
then when that happens you can run to
the bank very happily but for every
other instance what will happen is it'll
actually shift the buying curve up more
people will take the second highest
option which used to be your highest
because it got anchored against the most
expensive thing anchor something really
high knowing that it's okay that they
don't take it because what happens the
first number someone sees
psychologically all other numbers they
hear after that get compared in relation
to that first number which means
everything else seems much smaller